[Musique]
bonjour nouvelle édition du 7 8
politique votre rendez vous mensuel avec
la politique sur tv 78 au sommaire de ce
mois de septembre le parti communiste
vers un nouveau départ alors que la fête
de l'humanité organisé chaque année par
la formation vient de se refermer pierre
laurent secrétaire national cherche une
ligne à tenir pour les prochaines
élections européennes si une alliance
avec la france un sou me semble
impossible
une union du reste de la gauche est elle
possible et puis en seconde partie à des
missions nous reviendrons aussi sur la
rentrée de la république en marche entre
affaires benalla malaise de certains
députés
elle départ du gouvernement mais aussi
d'importants dossiers de réformes à
mener
en plateau béatrice piron député la
république en marche et puis ils
reviendront aussi au cours de cette
édition sur la présidence des
républicains des yvelines et la
démission du maire de coignières luc
miserait bonjour bonjour et bienvenue
vous êtes membre du conseil
départemental du parti communiste à la
fête de l'humanité vient de se refermer
est ce que vous êtes satisfait du bilan
alors pour la fête de l'humanité oui
plus de 500 milles du but visiteur
des centaines de débats des spectacles
donc du divertissement des espaces
dédiés aux livres au cinéma aux arts
en tout genre et notamment pour rendre
hommage à jack ralite un très grand
personnage qui est décédé dans l'année
donc c'est un très grand cru de la fête
de l'humanité que cette fête 2018
un regret c'est qu'elle soit autant pas
si passé sous silence par les médias
donc je vous remercie d'en parler
d'autant plus il ya eu des échanges de
grande qualité que ce soit sur le plan
politique mais aussi sur l'économie
sociale et solidaire sur le plan des
luttes syndicales sur le plan
international puisqu'on a aussi un
village du monde avec des représentants
de pratiquement tous les continents
donc vraiment un un espace de fraternité
et d'humanité parce qu'on parle beaucoup
en tout cas de l'aspect concert festif
avec des artistes qui se produisent mais
c'est aussi l'occasion d'organiser des
réunions des groupes de travail des
échanges c'est productif alors c'est pas
exactement des réunions des groupes de
travail mais ce sont une multitude de
débats qui qui qui se passe avec des
endroits qui sont plus
institutionnalisée comme l'agora de
l'humanité qui met dans de nombreux
stands départementaux il ya des débats
qui sont organisées en lien avec
l'actualité nationale
parfois sur des problématiques plus
locale et c'est vraiment d'une extrême
richesse donc il ya les deux qui qui qui
cohabitent et qui cohabitent très bien
et les gens pouvant passer de l'un à
l'autre
et puis les stands présentent très
souvent leurs spécialités régionales
donc on peut aller là aussi déguster
dans le sud-ouest déconfit
des huîtres ailleurs donc c'est vraiment
un espace de convivialité convivialité
mais aussi des discours politiques un
pierre laurent a fait trois propositions
lors de ce discours pour l'année à venir
construire partout dès maintenant les
grandes lois sociales et écologiques
pour le pays tenir des états généraux du
progrès social écologique aussi en
europe début 2019 et puis se préparer
pour la bataille des municipales
on remarque l'écologie qui a une part
importante aujourd'hui l'écologie passe
par le parti communiste
ça fait très longtemps que l'écologie
est un thème abordé par le parti
communiste
certains détracteurs ont voulu nous
présenter comme des productiviste et et
nous notre ambition elle est d'allier
les deux mais toujours avec au centre
l'intérêt de l'humain parce qu'on a
besoin à la fois de développer du
travail et en même temps on a besoin
d'être soucieux de l'environnement
donc les partis écologistes n'existait
pas encore que déjà il y avait des
initiatives qui était prise dans les
municipalités communistes etc etc alors
avec plein de contradictions oui par
exemple
pendant très longtemps les choses
évoluent un petit peu mais pendant très
longtemps ne pouvait être qualifiée d'
écologistes que ceux qui étaient contre
le nucléaire
le parti communiste ne s'est jamais
prononcée contre le nucléaire
il n'a pas dit non plus qu'il ne fallait
pas rééquilibré bien sûr qu'il faut
rééquilibrer pour faire en sorte mais il
nous semble réaliste de dire qu'il faut
lé étalé dans le temps
non pas pour le renvoyer aux calendes
grecques comme certains
soit offert mais parce que il ya une
nécessité de prendre en compte ces
questions d'environnement
donc c'est pas une découverte
par contre c'est un sujet d'une
actualité tellement brûlante que qu'il
faut bien d'en parler mais par exemple
à l'écouter on pourrait croire qu
emmanuel macron est le chantre de 2,2 de
la mise en place de la coop 21 et c'est
alors que dans le même temps c'est lui
qui a mis des bus sur partout en france
et c'est lui qui attaque la sncf au
moment où il faudrait la renforcer la
développer pour que par exemple le fret
marchandises soit énormément développés
c'est une possibilité les
infrastructures existent une des grandes
sources de pollution c'est la pollution
par exemple des camions il ya des
camions qui doivent circuler c'est c'est
légitime il y en a beaucoup qui
pourraient être mises sur les trains et
faire en sorte qu' il y ait moins de
pollution atmosphérique en tout cas liés
au gaz produit par le diesel et aux
particules que ce même diesel produit
donc il y avait des possibilités encore
faut-il se sont emparés est ce que les
discussions justement avec ce discours
que vous tenez ces propositions que vous
faites peut s'engager avec europe
écologie par exemple ou avec d'autres
partenaires génération aussi le
mouvement benoît hamon mais avec avec
europe ecologie les verts
il s'est déjà engagé il ya bien
longtemps si vous vous rappelez aux
élections départementales
j'étais candidat avec comme suppléante
une candidate europe ecologie les verts
donc c'est nos échanges existent depuis
fort longtemps donc la problématique
elle est de voir comment on peut les
inscrire dans la durée par exemple
assure sur les européennes il agit des
pistes de communication ont fait que les
choses sont en évolution mais il
semblerait que europe écologie les verts
tiennent à avoir sa propre liste donc on
verra si dans le temps ça continue à
s'affirmer comme cela en tout cas nous
souhaitons comme nous l'avons été
pendant la présidentielle
être acteur du rassemblement je tiens à
rappeler que le parti communiste a été
le seul parti politique à dire il faut
faire le rassemblement et à ne pas dire
dans le même temps voilà mon candidat et
venez tout le monde derrière moi donc y
compris en sachant au préalable ce que
ça peut nous coûter en terme de
représentativité mais ça nous semblait
l'attitude la plus responsable et bien
là il en va de même pour les européennes
un donc vous disiez tout à l'heure ça
paraît un peu compliquée avec la france
insoumise bah oui à partir du moment où
un des unes des grandes divergences
qu'on a avec eux c'est que le
rassemblement c'est pas tout le monde
derrière moi ni derrière nous le parti
communiste ni derrière jean-luc
mélenchon et la france insoumise
c'est le rassemblement c'est comment on
unis et comment on travaille à l'union
des forces de gauche qui sont
véritablement des forces de gauche
on le voit bien toute la politique qui a
été de 2 tentation hégémonique un qu'on
doit à françois mitterrand dont
jean luc mélenchon ne se prive pas de
dire qu'il est son disciple et bien
c'est ça qui a amené l'éclatement de la
gauche et l'état dans lequel elle a
aujourd'hui
donc si on veut reconstruire une gauche
qui soit crédible et qui soit en mesure
de mettre en place de véritables une
faire état politique de justice sociale
eh bien ça passe par le fait que les uns
et les autres se respecte et que tout le
monde trouve sa place à l'intérieur
et n'oublie pas qu'on travaille avec et
pour une population qui souffre
terriblement en ce moment donc la
réconciliation avec jean luc mélenchon
la france insoumise ce n'est pas pour
demain mais c'est possible à partir du
moment où on se respecte et où chacun a
envie de faire un pas vers l'autre
aujourd'hui et depuis que jean luc
mélenchon a lancé sa sa campagne pour la
présidentielle c'est tout le monde
derrière moi donc nous ça nous semble
pas être les conditions du rassemblement
et c'est pas de ce rassemblement là que
l'on veut et apparemment la majorité des
français veulent un autre type de
rassemblement que celui là sinon il
aurait pu il aurait peut-être même dû
être en meilleure position encore qu'il
n'a été malgré l'excellent score qu'il a
réalisées avant les prochaines
européennes il y aura aussi le congrès
national du parti communiste ce sera fin
novembre comment se prépare ce congrès
ça fait déjà plusieurs mois qu'on est en
débat alors en interne dans nos
structures les plus local également au
niveau départemental et puis
progressivement tout cela va remonter on
a un vote intermédiaire sur une base
commune de départ qui lui va avoir lieu
début octobre donc tout un processus qui
qui est en marche et qui nous mobilise
de manière conséquente comment se porte
le parti communiste dans le département
des yvelines
en cette rentrée justement badens dans
la difficulté mais dans la difficulté
comme toutes les forces de gauche on l'a
rappelé tout à l'heure dans le même
temps on a de l'ecoute autour de cette
fête de l'humanité on a des tas de gens
qui sont venus par exemple pour la
première fois qu'ils ont découvert
quelque chose qu'ils ne soupçonnaient
pas on a des gens qui adhère au parti
communiste donc on travaille à elle
développé on est dans un département qui
est quand même très très compliqué où il
y a par exemple au conseil départemental
que des élus de droite se pose un peu
question quand même donc c'est difficile
et puis les actions conjuguées des
gouvernements chirac sarkozy hollande
est aujourd'hui macron font que ce qui
est le fait marquant du ressenti de la
majorité des gens c'est un certain
fatalisme et nous ce qu'on essaye de
dire c'est que ce fatalisme et bien n'en
est pas un et qu'il y a des possibilités
jamais il n'y a eu autant de richesse
dans notre pays jamais il ya eu autant
de dividendes distribués aux
actionnaires le la france est elle le
tient le record du nombre de dividendes
distribués aux actionnaires et manu
acron a souhaité supprimer l isf
il n'y a pas véritablement une lutte
efficace qui est menée contre l'évasion
fiscale mais ça on le comprend bien
il est issu des banques d affaires c les
banques d affaires qu organise sa donc
par définition ça a été comme quand on
désignera à la tête de l'union
européenne l'ancien premier ministre du
luxembourg qui est le premier à
pratiquer l'évasion fiscale pour
enrichir son pays donc dans des
conditions comme ça c'est les choses
sont très très compliqué et nous on
travaille avec veillées les consciences
à travailler avec les gens pour leur
dire il ya autre chose qui est possible
mais pour ça et bien il faut qu'on se
réunisse et qu'on soit plus efficace
ensemble merci
il miserait je rappelle que vous êtes
également élu attrapé à la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
merci à vous merci quant à nous nous
poursuivons ce numéro avec l'actualité
politique de ce mois ci marqué par la
campagne pour la présidence des
républicains des yvelines pierre bédier
président du conseil départemental à
face à alexandra dublanche conseillère
régionale tenue entre autres par valérie
pécresse l'élection par les adhérents se
déroulera le 13 et le 14 octobre
retour sur le lancement de campagne de
pierre bédier un nouveau défi après
avoir été secrétaire d'état député et
maire de mantes-la-jolie l'une des plus
grandes villes du territoire pierre
bédier se lance à la conquête de la
fédération les républicains le président
du conseil départemental démarre sa
campagne dans un contexte compliqué pour
son parti recule au niveau national
perte de 90 % des adhérents en 2017 dans
les yvelines
sa priorité pour inverser la tendance
retourner sur le terrain auprès des
militants retrouver une envie de militer
et de militer autour d'une génération
montante qu'on doit préparer pour les
futures élections et autour de
propositions claires aussi bien au plan
national qu'au plan local la dimension
programmatique ce travail là doit être
une de nos priorités
mais pas que il faut aussi faire de la
détection et puis de l'animation animer
des soirées débats créer une école des
cadres politiques pour faire de la
formation travaillait auprès des
militants et sympathisants quelques
ébauches de propositions que pierre
bédier a présenté devant près de 500
personnes au pecq et dans la salle ses
principaux soutiens qui met en avant son
expérience et son envie de rassembler et
un certain nombre de jeunes qui ont
également fait le déplacement ont fait
pas du jeunisme et c'est important de
s'appuyer sur un socle d'expérience
parce qu'aujourd'hui ce dont a besoin
effectivement la droite c'est d'abord de
vraiment refaire le terrassement et puis
ensuite on construira tranquillement la
la maison et ça ça demande un petit peu
de temps c'est le seul aujourd'hui
qui puisse rassembler tous des militants
qu'ils puissent demain également aider
tous les ai vus pour reconstruire notre
fédération parce que c'est un homme qui
a une histoire
c'est un homme de terrain et c'est avant
tout un militant c'est à dire de ceux
qui on peut compter
c'est énorme cogneur qui mouille sa
chemise pour les autres et c'est un
homme qui représenterait très bien les
convictions les à l'ère pierre bédier
fera face notamment au duo de candidats
composé par alexandra dublanchet othman
deux roues les élections à la présidence
de la fédération les républicains sont
programmées les 13 et 14 octobre
prochains
autre élection qui se profile celle pour
la municipalité de coignières le maire
jean pierre sauvestre a décidé de se
retirer en raison de tensions au sein de
son assemblée des conflits avec une
partie de sa majorité suite notamment à
ce projet finalement abandonné de
rapprochement avec la ville de maurepas
le maire jette l'épongé
l'équipe en place arrivera-t-elle à se
mettre d'accord où les électeurs seront
ils appelés aux urnes
on écoute jean pierre semestre pour moi
c'est la meilleure solution parce que je
considère qu'il convient maintenant de
donner la parole aux poignets rien c'est
le souhait que je que je fais pour leur
permettre de peut même de choisir
l'avenir de leur ville
sereinement après d'une préparation
d'élections peut-être qui intervient
donc plus tard mais c'est une des pistes
y ont tout à fait personnelle et je
considère que pour le bienfait de mon
équipe ma démission je ne peux pas
appliqué mon équipe justement dans cette
démission c'est une démission une
démarche tout à fait personnelle oui la
suite du 7-8 politique à présent avec
une députée béatrice piron bienvenue en
plateau et député à la république en
marche on va parler de la rentrée de
votre formation politique les dernières
semaines elle était aussi a été plutôt
agitée entre la sphère benalla des
départs de ministres de députés aussi
mêmes qui ont changé de deux camps
politiques
frédéric dumas justement qui a quitté l
om pour lui d ea a déclaré on a
l'impression d'être sur le titanic est
ce que l om est en train de sombrer
pas du tout c'est une impression
totalement personnel je connais bien
frédéric nous avons travaillé l'année
dernière ensemble se rendent aussi
communs concernant l'audiovisuel
c'est une décision qu'elle a prise seul
pendant l'été qui a vraiment surpris
tout le monde et je crois qu'elle n'est
pas du tout suivi
donc c'est pas des députés c'est un des
buts est donc ou une non je pense que
c'est un choix personnel
est-ce que vous avez des inquiétudes en
tant qu'élu de la république en marche
sur votre formation sur la façon de
fonctionner on entend aussi les
difficultés de dialogue quelquefois
entre les parlementaires le gouvernement
aussi l élection de richard ferrand par
exemple qui est une élection qui a été
vécu par certains des des élus comme
décision le fait du prince comme une
décision de l'état
pas du tout nous avons nous avons voté
ça est étroitement démocratique donc je
crois que c'est la première fois quand
même que dans un mouvement politique
dans un groupe parlementaire
on a la chance de pouvoir donc choisir
le candidat qui sera présentée par à
part notre mouvement donc ça n'a pas été
justement nommé mais on nous étions tous
présents et nous avons tous voté nos
certes comme dans toute élection il ya
des gens qui sont plus ou moins déçu
mais je crois que tout le monde a
exprimé conquois ça fonctionnera très
bien et on est quand même contents du
résultat
on peut pas on peut pas se fâcher
forcément parce que c'était pas notre
favori moi je vais voter pour une femme
j'aurais bien aimé qu'il y ait une femme
au perchoir
mais bon la majorité a choisi que ce
soit monsieur ferrand donc on fonctionne
avec monsieur ferrand qui avait bien
fonctionné bien mené le groupe jusqu'à
présent
alors certes ça fait quelques vagues ça
fait une rentrée un petit peu animée
puisque on a eu cette élection pour la
présidence de l'assemblée nationale et
ensuite une action pour le président de
groupe
mais gilles legendre hier aussi a été
applaudi
de façon unanime en ce qui concerne la
sphère benalla au moment où nous
enregistrons cette émission c'était ce
matin l'audition d'alexandre benalla il
est comment je vis à vis cette audition
non pas du tout non dans un engin avait
autre chose à faire ce matin alors je
crois l'assemblée nationale a choisi
déjà depuis l'été de d'interrompre
d'arrêter cette commission denquête jeu
pour moi c'est vraiment un fait divers
c'est vraiment du passé que bon jeu faut
laisser la justice maintenant suivre son
cours non ça n'affecte que on quitte le
côté politique avec les relations avec
les français le sondage dans les
sondages la cote de popularité du
président est plutôt basse il ya des
réformes qui sont pas toujours très bien
vu les efforts demandés aux retraités
par exemple par exemple aussi les
déclarations du président il suffirait
d'aller de l'autre côté de la rue pour
trouver du travail et ce qu'il a déclaré
à un jeune qui était qui était venue
lors des journées du patrimoine à
l'elysée ya un gouffre qui se creuse
nous il ya des gens qui qui conteste ya
des gens qui se plaignent mais il ya
toujours eu ça à tous à toutes les
époques
alors certes les sondages un petit peu
baissé mais on sait toujours que savès
au fur et à mesure donc des réformes
mais on a au jour toujours des contacts
et on est souvent sur terrain sur les
marchés en faisant du porte à porte donc
on pourra évoquer éventuellement les les
grandes marches que nous avons fait donc
ce printemps où on a beaucoup de
français qui nous soutiennent et qui
continue de nous dire continuer il faut
réformer il faut aller de l'avant il ne
faut pas s'arrêter
donc moi j'ai beaucoup d'espoir qu'est
ce qui ce fait va dans le bon sens ça
correspond à ce que vous attendiez
s'engager c'est notre engagement c'était
notre programme en continu on le
poursuit donc il ya des élus aussi qui
vous rejoignent je parlais de toute
l'équipe mais on pourrait citer stéphane
mirambeau le maire de villepreux qui
officiellement a décidé de se rallier à
la république en marche en tout cas de
le faire savoir publiquement il ya
d'autres contacts avec des élus locaux
les maires vous préparez déjà le terrain
pour les municipales peut-être alors il
ya divers contacts
on a des contacts avec des élus j'irai
quasiment toutes les villes pas
forcément des mères mais
il ya bien plus que les maires qu'ils
soient élus dans une ville donc nous
avons des adjoints nous avons des
conseillers municipaux évidemment
partout en france
donc aujourd'hui sur les yvelines donc
la république armand je représente douze
mille adhérents
donc faut bien imaginer qui en a dans
toutes les communes qui qui qui
fonctionne au sein de comités locaux
donc il ya plus de 100 comités locaux
vont donc aujourd'hui qui sont actifs
qui font des opérations qui font du
porte à porte qui font du tractage on
est en train de préparer donc notre
notre entrée des territoires qu aura
lieu le 29 septembre et pour cela donc
dès ce week-end on va on va tracter on
va distribuer donc plus de dix mille
tracts sur le département pour pouvoir
inviter les gens donc à notre rentrée
des territoires la matinée sera réservée
plutôt à des gens déjà militants déjà
organisé dans un comité avec justement
un début de discussion avec une
intervention de brice couturier pour
pouvoir commencer à préparer répond aux
questions des gens qui comptent monter
un programme municipal donc et
sous-vêtements liste et l'après midi
donc on recevra tous les français tous
les marcheurs le grand public pour pour
parler donc justement de comment
fonctionne des opérations de grandes
marches et surtout aussi de l'europe
mais surtout de l'europe c'est le coeur
un petit peu aussi du programme et c'est
la même direction et c'est la prochaine
élection donc les tiges en outre tout à
fait le parti joue beaucoup
cette élection le parti la france comme
tous les fait qu'il y ait un vote
contestataire aussi peut-être lorsqu'on
regarde les sondages toujours pareil
mais le rassemblement national fait jeu
égal avec la république en marche n'est
au-dessus des 20% pour les deux
formations politiques et c'est pour ça
que nous nous battons tous les jours
parce que il est important de préserver
la france pour éviter que des gens trop
peut être un ministre que ce soit donc
populistes ou à l'extrême droite
arrivent et prennent trop de pouvoir sur
cette europe s'est déjà produit dans
certains pays
donc aujourd'hui on essaye de trouver
des alliés y compris en europe tant
qu'il y aura aussi donc la grande marche
européenne et dans d'autres pays
et c'était important que que les
français puissent voir le côté positif
de l'europe et s'engage pour europe mais
je ne suis pas trop craintif pour notre
département où au moins pour ma
circonscription parce que bon je suis
souvent sur terrain et mêmes
même avec des contacts des gens qui ne
sont pas de notre mouvement aujourd'hui
je crois que beaucoup de gens essayent
de quand même défendre l'europe
je vais revenir au local est juste ou
faire réagir sur sur les élus locaux
aussi parce que si certains vous
rejoignent d'autres critiquent aussi la
baisse des dotations progressive de
l'état envers les collectivités alors
nationalement il ya une hausse donc
nationalement ca a augmenté par contre
forcément il ya des villes qui part des
habitants des villes qui en gagnent donc
tout le monde peut pas gagner c'est la
loi mécanique de des dotations donc
forcément il ya des villes qui ont fait
rire et du réduisent leur service aussi
qui sont en difficulté qui embauchent
moins d'agents aussi alors ça fait ça
fait des années que les dotations baisse
donc des fois les fonds sont des caisses
sont vides
et effectivement ils sont mais on a
encouragé on encourage les collectivités
locales à faire quand même des économies
puisque les français en ont marre de
payer des impôts et on ne peut pas
fournir des services à volonté et ne pas
payer donc je crois qu'il faut trouver
le juste équilibre
lors des trois tous ces élus d'être de
race de se rassurer que l'état ne les
abandonnera pas c'est le sentiment qui
prévaut quelques fois
non non non je vois pas en quoi l'état
les abandonnerait donc ils ont tous
crins en début d'année sur les
suppressions attaques d'habitations
donc certes les français vont gagner du
pouvoir d'achat dès cet automne dès le
mois d'octobre puisque 80% des français
vont voir leur taxe d'habitation baissé
de 30%
mais les collectivités n'ont rien perdu
puisque c'est qu'on pensait donc à
l'euro près et que chaque commune donc
va recevoir donc un dégrèvement donc de
l'état
mais peut-être un bon pour conclure sur
cette taxe d'habitation justement vous
parlez de 80% des français pour ceux qui
nous écoutent quels sont les grands
critères peut-être savoir s'ils sont ou
non concerné alors oui il ya des sites
qui leur permet de calculer précisément
mais bon pour une famille avec deux
enfants je crois au dessus de 4000 euros
de revenus par mois
lise auront donc leur 30% de dégrèvement
merci patrice prions d'être venu sur ce
plateau parler de cette rentrée pour la
république en marche merci à vous on se
retrouve le 17 octobre pouvoir un
prochain 7,8 politique d'ici là
l'actualité politique est à suivre dans
notre journal quotidien avec grigoriy
canal et à bientôt
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]